- Ici c'est les beaux poissons.
- C'est l'heure du marché pour
le chef Jean-Christophe Poirier.
Poissons, charcuteries, fromages
assiettes de son restaurant,
le St-Lawrence, qui vient
de recevoir une étoile Michelin.
JEAN-CHRISTOPHE POIRIER
chef, Restaurant St-Lawrence
- Ça m'a pris quelques jours
avant de réaliser qu'est-ce qui
arrivait. Donc... c'est bien
pour l'équipe, c'est bien pour
le restaurant, c'est bien pour
Vancouver aussi.
- Et pour le chef, qui réalise
ainsi un rêve. Cette étoile est
la consécration d'une carrière
commencée il y a 25 ans,
à Montréal, avec notamment
deux ans au prestigieux Toqué,
avant le départ pour Vancouver
en 2004.
Là, la carrière de Jean-
Christophe Poirier décolle,
grâce à son travail acharné
dans plusieurs restaurants
et l'ouverture du St-Lawrence
en 2017.
Un restaurant à l'image
de ce Québécois originaires s s,
authentique, chaleureux.- On ret
et puis on est transporté soit
au Québec ou en France et puis
je voulais mettre ma touche
personnelle, donc les
antiquités, les photos de ma
famille, de moi ou de mes
enfants sont un peu apartout.
Comem ça, je me sens chez moi.
- 45 couverts, une équipe
de 10 personnes, et un menu
qui réinvente des classiques
de la cuisine française
à la sauce québécoise.
Avec un ingrédient roi.
- Le sirop d'érable est beaucoup
utilisé, c'est un peu aussi
ma touche québécoise sur la
cuisine française. Par exemple,
je vais faire une crème caramel
au foie gras, mais au lieu du
sucre, je remplace par du sirop
d'érable. Et aussi en janvier,
février, mars, on fait le menu
sirop d'érable.
- Des recettes que Jean-
Christophe vient de publier dans
un livre.
- Depuis son ouverture,
le St-Lawrence collectionne
les prix, dont celui d'être
sur la liste des cinq meilleurs
restaurants du Canada.
Sa clientèle est fidèle.
- Cette étoile Michelin,
c'est la cerise sur le gâteau.
- Moi, je trouve que c'est
une... c'est formidable pour le
type de restaurant qu'on a ici,
c'est parfait. Je ne veux pas
chasser la deuxième, mais si
elle vient, c'est parce qu'on
fait un travail formidable.
- Un travail formidable que
Jean-Christophe Poirier veut
poursuivre : se concentrer sur
son restaurant, améliorer
la qualité du menu et continuer
à offrir du bonheur à tous ceux
et celles qui poussent la porte
du St-Lawrence.
Ici Catherine François,
Radio-Canada, Vancouver.